born and raised outside north america
paid his dues
as an assistant to the nba the last 18
years doncic another great pass to
deandre jordan that's going to be a
tandem to watch this year on the
defensive end
luca now jordan
now his second so out of the game he's
going to go here's lucas handles i think
we're going to get some globetrotting
stuff too
this year so it's going to be fun curly
deal is going out look at that
it's a good look you faked me out no
player likes to look where they're
able to finish in the open court
[Applause]
oh luca what a block against favors
second try is challenged and missed
eagles up on luca jazz have a foul to
give
luca launches
he gave it to him he gave it to him
and closed the second quarter out the
way they did they're going to be in
control
eight for 14 from the three-point line
luca
adding to that from the three-point line
and
hanging out with the soldier indiana
trip in january
wow nice what a finds and
what a jam by cleva last minute
take a look felipe made the cut
luca with the supreme vision for the jam
chance
here comes luca luca from just inside
half court
he got it
chuck look at me i'm giving you your
love right now
coop is going bananas down there right
now harp about wine i'm dying he told me
and shoot around
la turning down a lot of open shots
right now lebron
cut for the weak side luka blocked him
twice wow
that's very alert defensive play well
luca very alertly regarding lebron james
underneath
lebron didn't see him the first time but
the second time the mavs have made them
work for this one
the time coming off the bar that's what
you want to do good look up right here
oh luca finds dennis the long pass
completed
and the dagger how is that for an
exclamation point on the night hold a
finishing kick
i mentioned getting to the finish line
is what dallas needed to do
they are kicking like a sprinter after a
long run to the finish
it's a great dump excellent pass from
luca
elevation
jonas geripko went into the game and
luca goes right around him and dunks
again
yeah oh and he went down hard too there
you go
it's strong it is now the pick and
choose what you go for
when it comes to dunks it's just with
that quick step
right before thanksgiving indeed
into the corner lucas
how did he do it how did he do it
that is luca magic take a look at this
god what a pass got it off in time
plenty of time what a
shot wow he is a special young man
there's no question about it by the way
that was a heck of a pass like
yes it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the legend of luca continuing to be
written
for the rookie and smart toblin off
as he contested that was clearly a foul
doncic should have gotten the three and
one
stay tuned one minute left
luca it opens up he drives a luca dunk
he's looking for a foul too well unless
you let him
left him wide open forcing him to be to
shoot a good cut right here
[Applause]
and rudy gay can live there i mean he's
been hurt some but
luca long attempt oh look the magic
strikes again
pump three off the inbounds pass you
called it skin
you take a lock at the great finish that
time by
luca he practices that stuff
orange draws the defense touch pass by
matthews luke at the end of the shot
clock
got it back with dennis a one-handed
three luca magic
in the garden
[Applause]
no it's gonna come back to you are you
ready
he was ready knocked it down desperation
three
late clock push it got numbers that's
five on four right now luca ready to
have a go right now cody zeller oh what
a finish
[Applause]
this is all luca here just attacking in
the open court
and showing off that tremendous skill
luca against austin rivers creeping down
towards a minute to play in the first
quarter
with a step up from the baseline
fifth year player from colorado
halfcourt heave
[Applause]
center half court bank shot beyond half
court either
that's a good finish by luca closing out
the second quarter mavericks need to
regroup
in a bad way
well if you're looking for a lifeline
maybe that's one
drives on milsip bounces off of once
takes him down low
[Applause]
one more time let me give it to you like
kevin mchale used to give it to us
[Music]
dallas has got the lead doncic
throws down a sledgehammer don't sleep
on luca
drove it early had the mismatch you
thought i was going to lay it up
no i'm flushing it on you he's feeling
it tonight
yes earth with two shots tonight this is
the pull up
there's dorian again
as luca finds dory and finney smith that
was perfect
oh my goodness not an easy pass
you can find guys to go around curry
and thompson and durant and all those
guys
if they're if they're smart as
finney smith dunks
really nice passing a 40
point shooter oh
he may not be hitting his free throws
but sensational dimes just dropped by
luca take a look pick and roll
on the back to a rolling dwight powell
that pass it looks bleep right now
[Applause]
and an excellent look at it from our
incredible crew here in dallas doncic
works the foul banks it in and will have
a chance for three
from the dallas mavericks at the end of
the day
you've given up 54 points with nine
minutes to go into second
you gotta find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play
with intensity more rolling for kp
[Applause]
since january 1st 10th in the league 1.7
blocks
and then the german shepherd guards the
yard up one hand he got the bone of the
other
but watch luca just looked the defense
off
klipa finishes it up luka duncan with
two seconds left is gonna knock this
down
three two three
[Applause]
[Music]
he set that one up too oh great look at
it too off the glass
[Laughter]
he used his right hand it's a block yep
well that's 30 points in the third
quarter for luka doncic
with that three-pointer opportunity for
a four-point play
[Applause]
three minutes gone by here in the first
dodge fakes the behind the back pass
count it
[Applause]
there and then the fake wrap around pass
i'm not even sure he got fouled now they
called it on bledsoe
side out oh between the legs to klebo
soars to the rim stops it at his mouth
an incredible play
by luca with his left hand
cleba with a good hard roll but that is
some
shot pass
[Applause]
wow 19th assist
lou williams is on doncic
long three-pointer pucks it in luka
doncic from way downtown
and the lead is back up to seven
finney smith to inbound back to doncic
[Applause]
dodges pulls up three-pointer bang
bang it's good doncic wins the game
at the buzzer let's go
luca 3.7 seconds what
it's the shot he works on time and time
again
rhythm step back three that's in his
resume
what a performance by luca and the
mavericks
mama there goes that man
coming up on a minute left here in the
third doncic drive side step lay up
count it and one
chance for a traditional three-point
play
[Applause]
her father tom is undefeated doesn't
have the same speed as he once had but
has the upper body strength so created
space that
time with his upper body shielding wow
what a pass by
doncic inside to finish smith
look at the vision of luca
tremendous find and feed i mean he finds
a way to put the ball
well he's in position if uh he builds on
what he's done in the first week of the
season
to add another award to the trophy case
as luca dancing around adebayo
wow i like kevin mchale
as we take a look at the torture chamber
that skin alluded to
pretty good defense for about three or
four seconds
and luca got the best of it with that
little shot fake there
midpoint of the third quarter dallas
down by 13 behind
behind the back again and a slam dunk by
carly stein
a double behind the back that is so cute
how about that
for the triple double now for luca what
a 10th assist oh that's
excellent that'll make the uh
nice pass kp didn't let him bully him
double team on luca once again a b.e.a
beautiful pass
dimes being dropped here
maps have needed this volcano first
quarter out of luca with 14 points to
stay connected
as porter goes to dozier inside blocked
by luca dozier got it back loose ball
oh foul that's good defense that time by
doncic
coming over from the weak side helping
out
the eraser get some easy looks at the
basket
lucas stops cam radish on the drive and
picks his pocket
and then luca nice little
behind-the-back feed ran that fast break
so well so nifty so patient that time by
doncic
what a steal and luca also coming up
with a steal
and again an outstanding lead
and portland now 13 of 25 from three as
a team
don got that one to go
leaning and leaping luka doncic what
we're seeing from portland
they've come out here now and they're
really setting its own
they're setting the tone more on defense
now this is just an incredible shot
look at that the defensive guy came over
the top
and boston up by one
doncic the handles the fake
the fade it's pure luca
doncic with a fade away three
to put dallas in front by two
[Laughter]
doncic
huge shot mavericks lead at 107 105.
doncic down to three seconds two seconds
tons for the win oh yeah
luca duncan the decker
on consecutive possessions and down the
stretch
luca gets to his spot step back deep
three two people on him
and he's showing why he is in a all-star
luca donches de don coming up big
for his ball club
[Applause]
doncic leading the mavericks and scoring
in assists
and rebounds lobs it into carly stein
and an easy bucket
well again the size to throw it over the
top
orlando's tie with cleveland for the
most games this year of not reaching 114
of them they made it to 100 here in the
fourth quarter but they've got no answer
for stopping luca and the mavericks
makes it a little more difficult for you
here with under two minutes to go
they've shotted well but they've cooled
off since the first half ton chich
knocks down the three as he's heating up
at just the right time it comes off the
fingertips of luka doncic
a put away three just two of ten for
three point range for the ninth but
sometimes ga timing is everything
it is first of two straight games
between the mavs and clippers
george rising luca rebounds the best
look
up over the top to finish smith running
the floor
and throwing it down and the outlet pass
absolutely exquisite clippers without
serge ibaka as well as patrick beverly
doncic leans into leonard hits the three
plus the foul up until the lunge to try
to contest the shot
and then the strength of doncic
to get hit and then still be able to
shoot the ball
from that range
the love to cleeba who oops the alley
[Applause]
well dodgers just ripped it through
and throws the lob to the cutting
cleaver
just terrific vision good catch by cliva
doncic crowded by the blazers flips it
behind his back what a fine hard away
junior that's a beautiful play there
[Music]
[Applause]
doncic going downhill back out to cleva
and cleva dialed in tonight 9.3 assists
per game fourth best another
no look flip it back
he knows his bigs like to camp out
behind a three-point line
and more importantly he knows where
they're
shot clock down to five again
[Applause]
doncic long three-pointer bang luca
dodges from way downtown
to the second shot and then finally
a big time another step back three
by doncic in terms of the strength
department shot clock at four
doncic with randall on him long
three-pointer hooks and up
shot he banks it in luka dunches from
downtown
he smiles and laughs so this is the bank
right here is open for dante
trying to get himself right after a one
of six friday night shooting the ball
against denver
powell a wide open lane coming over late
but too late and not
big enough strong enough to stop powell
paddy mills with a foul but powell
has got a chance for a three-point play
pocket pass that time from luka doncic
by sets to screen and roll that was
between
hertl's legs i think that hey nutmeg
yeah yeah
philadelphia by seven right now early
second quarter
nice pass by luka doncic to powell for
the flush
well here he comes and like mark said he
keeps simmons on his back and just
flips it up to howard
what i mean too powell
got to get it in here's luca gets it
away
it's gone a doncic dagger
as he was stumbling he somehow got it to
go
whether it's a three or two is
remarkable in and of itself let's see
was he behind the line
let's see if he got it off in time watch
the foot oh yeah that's a three and he
got it away in time that's good that's a
win
what a shot
and what a dagger for memphis
i mean falling forward stumbling out of
control he's at the rim when the ball
goes through the net
his momentum carrying him forward as
luca wins it with a three
puts up 29 points 25 in the second half
and a huge
road win he can shoot though i'm not
going to i'm not going to bust your
bubba on that
no bubble busting please a long three
oh and speaking of a guy who can shoot
and off the glass too
two on the shot clock dodge for three
[Applause]
knocking it out the paw luca knocking
down the long ball
having his weight mama piggles and match
71 right now lin got to the rim but
didn't finish
watch will he run luca in transition
looks off the defense and he found that
running
willy cauley stein he looked up here at
you
what's up my man so that means this guy
can see he did look right towards you
there you go
dunks it home man that's good stuff
i think they're going to wave off the
end one basket so
he still scores anyhow luca takes it
inside and powell cleans up the mess
the outstanding start for dallas here's
the last one
inside luca into a crowd
somehow got it to powell nice three
right there but that scream
man that was bone chilling luke has got
a pass to the basket
all the way to the hole wait a minute
luca i told hey joel you give this kid a
chance you're gonna like him the more
more you see him the more you're gonna
like
luca gets the triple on the move wow
amazing wow nine point lead but this
shot right here this is absolutely
bananas joel
look at luca luca loves it we all love
it luka